the security Council was briefed by
video link by the un's special
coordinator in Jerusalem tour wenisland
who said the last two weeks in the West
Bank had been terrible an alarming spike
in violence he criticized the recent
Israeli government announcement of a
further
5500 settler homes
unusually the U.S joined in the
criticism of Israel Deputy U.S
ambassador Robert Wood said he condemned
recent attacks by Israeli settlers in
the West Bank we extend our condolences
to the families of those affected and
have underscored to the Israeli
government the importance of holding
fully accountable and Prosecuting those
responsible for these acts of violence
we were also deeply troubled by Israel's
recent announcements advancing more than
5 000 settlement units and reports of
changes to Israel's system of settlement
Administration that expedite the
planning and approval of settlements
at the same time the Security Council is
meeting the UN published its annual
children and armed conflict report every
year it includes a blacklist of the
armies and armed groups that kill and
injure children once again this year
Israel was not put on that list
the UN says that's because there was a
decrease in the number of children
killed by Israel in 2022 at a news
conference I asked the UN special
representative first to reread the
warning to Israel she put in last year's
report
should substantial airstrikes and
Rockets resulting from the May 2021
escalation of hostilities repeat itself
in 2022 parties to the conflict should
be listed
so I don't understand why Israel is not
listed there was another conflict in
Gaza in 2022 the total number of deaths
is less because the conflict in May 2021
was 11 days long the conflict in August
2022 was three days long but Israel did
exactly the same thing it fired
indiscriminately bombed indiscriminately
and killed children you've made a clear
warning and then you wimped out I think
it has to do with both the engagement
and the numbers that engagement did
occur and by December all sides had
agreed to exchange letters with me
letters letters don't change save
children's lives you know what's going
on this year I know this only covers
2022. Israel's already killed 27
children this year well this is why
we're very worried as we say we're very
concerned at an escalation that we're
noticing this year for the first time
because of the war in Ukraine Russia was
put on The report's Blacklist but Israel
has never been listed human rights
groups say they fear The Blacklist is
becoming a whitewash James Bay's Al
Jazeera at the United Nations